at the bonfire SXM will tweet out the
video we're talking about of a man in a
suit that we're trying to buy
suits you put this outfit on I'd look
ridiculous
yeah and dude I would fight rip
through the backs of all long and gangly
Jacob I would look just ridiculous in
this outfit you got to do it can you
imagine me it's like there it's small
looks like tiny pajamas on me yeah it's
up to my shame you can't have your
your wrists and forearms coming
out if there's a dress short if I have a
draft in the room and it strikes my
shins well I'm that machine I'll
be out on me off I'll be soft it's gonna
throw me off Jacob you're perfect Jacob
okay at home
you're just boys just tell us about it
yeah we don't have to be there we're
offering you the gift of blowjob robot
job get a rope job hi it's the bonfire
common sense radio sirius XM 95 I'm Dan
Soder and right across from me my radio
husband big Jay oakerson Oh Lou I know
you shouldn't come out today to smoke
are you not smoking yet I'm trying to
quit chantix is kicking in how many days
about 10 days now Hey really I'm still
smoking smoking okay
I'm confused about what chantix does
it's supposed to make you with tape you
can play through it I think I think you
might not work right I think I might
love cigarettes so much that I could
just overall I agree with you I feel
nauseous from smoking sometimes I go I
can stand an hour later I'll still go
smoke again look up Christine if there's
chantix failure story it doesn't work oh
you mean the underbelly the the dark
truth of chantix pretending his face
looks like that so I mean Kyle Dunnigan
did a grade on Instagram of Ray Liotta
with the face graph thing really yeah he
did ray liotta do a chantix cause really
that's really funny
God that is very funny yeah yeah
that's great was I just look because
they got that facelift yeah it's like
it's the best thing I ever did
oh and get that I just remember the
batshit crazy Ray Liotta tequila
commercial do you guys remember that
they'd play it before UFC events and in
just
like when you want something you need
it's like that you better have a shot at
it it's nuts he like
aggressively drinks tequila if I was a
bartender I wouldn't feel comfortable
serving him the whole point of chantix
is you you take the pill and it makes
you sick of smoking like it affects your
brain chemistry it's a nicotine let's
get to the smoking science in a second I
want to make sure that this is the
commercial I was talking about that's
batshit crazy with Ray Liotta I think he
just aggressively has a tequila it's
from a couple years ago treat your
bartender like a piece of weird
message if your bartender is a guy move
Rasik in but anyways you get the point
Ray Liotta goes in real feisty it just
yells at a bartender for tequila
oh sorry
it struck me as a weird commercial there
like this is a good image yeah here's
great news I'm half in the bag
there's chantix really work tell me the
truth what are my chances frankly not
good
what is this article where is it from
we've got to start checking our sources
here come on guys why quit calm and then
we keep smoking he goes chantix Carl
used it I don't think you liked it so
whatever man let's go out smoker but
it's saying if you're not taking it for
the you know whatever anxiety or should
also that it's gonna make you suicidal
no like accutane yeah maybe favourite
and Sebastian and stop putting you up in
balcony seats so you don't try to jump
yeah because Sebastian got the email
listen thanks for the tickets bad news
is in a hot zone yeah yeah hey bud you
have to bump me up a little bit
who are you are you having any crazy
dreams so you doing feeling no effects
it's feeling except for the cigarettes
tastes disgusting really really it's
made cigarettes gross yeah my tongue
feels like sandpaper yeah but you're
still going I love it
well when you love a thing Jay he's
along smokers is the doctor says gonna
take extra long what's the longest time
what's long you've quit smoking as long
as you without cigarette I want a six
months on chantix ten years ago I've
been smoking for almost 25 years
crazy smoking I would I would never have
the confidence of like dude I'll never
smoke a cigarette again because I think
about that if they hit those
missile sirens or whatever they have or
it's like the world's ending I'm gonna
be like dr. Campbell lights in a box
buddy yeah let's get it going I'll be
back outside of fuckhead I'll just be
ripping one up lighting it out like
bring it because that's how you
go you miss now you don't have that for
drinking and you know climbing to get
ripped to right now drinking I didn't
like how I was getting when I was drunk
like I wasn't as fun it was starting it
seems like the feeling of him I'm just
saying like you don't miss the feeling
like the good times of it enough to say
if the world's I think the missile
sirens are going all if the world you go
nuts and you do some drinks yeah yeah
yeah I would have like a I'd
have a Jameson and a like a Budweiser
bottle cool I'd do a couple
shots of whiskey put on some music you
want to like sip it again now
bang it back okay it's world you think
it's gross I don't think it's gross but
that's the way I'm used to drinking it
crossed
I don't like swish it around Jameson you
just hit just like pow can't he back
down that's what you would do yeah drink
Jameson with a bud back would you Jacob
workout just shoot up start writing a
book until the missiles hit no dude I'll
get aggressive yeah I don't really know
man if the missiles hit maybe a drink I
would definitely smoke a cigarette
you have no idea if there's no solution
if there's no answer to the thing
nothing I think I get I'd make sure I
got to Isabella in some capacity I'll
try that I would do heroin with her yeah
blast her off it's like when you're in
the air and you got to put the mask on
yeah I'm gonna blow it right in your
toes you got to do yourself first then
you help out that's what they tell you
in the sky yeah yeah
your own mask in the air no but that's
not with head that's not a that's an air
game it's not a heroin game heroin
you're gonna have to boot the kids up
absolutely cuz you're gonna up yeah
I don't wanna up you're in an odd
I would probably may not see what we
have in the house I just see what we
have in the houses you know let's clean
house a little bit just throw some
yeah some ninja this artisan yes
thanks for notice it is thank you for
paying attention to the house makes the
end of the world a whole lot easier
and there's the quests yeah what's that
you D what I would eat a box of cookies
oh you get like a real coke I might do
that tonight that's the debate I have in
my head at night every night
isn't that your jiggy ups apocalypse
plan that's what going off the diet is
is Jacob's going apocalypse he goes I
would eat ice cream right before bed it
exists that's mind blowing and we had to
do a drastic measure last night Sunday
cheat day and we order stuff there's a
place called Ray's candy store mm-hmm
in our neighbor around the corner that
will deliver to us we ordered was a
small order of deep-fried Oreos I
assumed was gonna be we were on the
phone when you were waiting delivered it
was gonna be two to four of them I
assume order I get an order of
deep-fried Twinkies you which was an
order of two they give you two of those
right yeah Christine three was it throws
yeah that's right that's orders three of
those so really we get them but it's not
expensive and all we it shows up and it
is they give us like a Clem
tines box yeah full fried Oreos yeah and
we ate I think we ate two or three
apiece and that was major restraint yeah
the next day I was gonna I'm gonna bring
these the Legion of skanks and just
forgot when I came back we heated one up
in the microwave and ate it it wasn't
quite it was still fantastic but not
what is good and then we went smoked a
cigarette and both said when we go
inside man they got to go in there I
mean there's 20 more and there's this
big will you there's a charcoal brazier
so good it's the kind of dessert
though where it's like good good good
ouch I hate life this is painful we have
two of them and you're like oh I have a
stomachache that's what I'm saying like
I I'll get that I'll see that order of
20 and I'll be like they know what
they're doing that's how many I want and
then I eat two and I'm like there's no
way you can get through but I'm telling
you just unconsciously you could
eat five and let's just you don't I'm a
little bit rendus for you and I'm a bad
little stinker with is brownie brittle
you can buy it in the airport I've seen
brownie before it looks good let me tell
you I will easily walk through a
bag oh the things that are like chips I
try to I try not to go through bags of
chips if I ever have chips now I tried
to go through a whole thing of candy if
I go through it now but uh but one thing
I will Duff Jesus look at those
things any kind of like dry I got it
like if I get like a bag of dried mango
mm-hmm the whole thing's good because
there's no going back to drive me you
know I mean if I open it up I'm just
gonna keep eating that until I'm done
with it so this place delivers candy to
you but I don't know if I can D but deep
fried they'll do it's Twix yeah
apparently it's like a New York
institution this place it's a little
hole no banana and Nutella milkshakes
it's pretty awesome I'm gonna have to
stop it's right by your house yeah yeah
it's unlike I guess it's in the East
Village it's on like six and AI think
yeah buddy the deep fried Oreos were
Jacob would you go deep-fried Oreos for
the apocalypse yeah you know carbs
eh he's an age sweet sweet hair oh it's
simple carbs and brown yeah he goes mr.
brownstone and some deep-fried Oreos so
you're just going to boot off
and eat chocolate and then hope you
don't wake up yeah it's pretty sweet
yourself to a deep-fried Oreo in the in
the current days it's a lot yeah no I'm
not it's a lot do you tell me I'm not
you know I remember we also threw that
out we vote to a couple sips in Ciroc
what do we do it's just trash to go we
made stone decisions and we're both like
yeah that's a I can't like if I do it's
like if I go with my it's the same
reason I haven't eaten six slices of
pizza in a sitting since I've been like
I guess probably in my 30s or so because
I'm like what you just don't eat five
slate I want to I just such a big girl
want to I'm a milkshake fans so the way
I look at that order is milkshake first
maybe a fried Oreo you know you do the
milkshake milkshake
my thought process always if I went and
ordered like a pizza myself I would
never get it just a small probably at
least a medium would that be I think my
franchise places and the idea was to get
yourself yeah franchise like a Domino's
when you sit down to a pizza you're like
well the pizza goes until it's finished
yeah it's just me I'm gonna keep eating
pizza yes I had a lot of pained nights
because of Domino's cuz of that remember
I got him medium I could eat the whole
thing even if I didn't want it and I got
cheesy bread yeah of course exactly and
you his aunt Cinna Stix you just fit but
someone who naturally doesn't do that
that's they're not working towards that
I've watched that we watch that
Christine gets mad at like girls that
come over our house all the time
looks like friends of hers or anything
they're like Karen now tiny Karen is
yeah she goes oh it's no mystery like
Karen ate a a chocolate chip cookie yeah
like the one that was like an hour the
one that you would like putting like see
if you can like get it to like frame the
inside of your teeth
you know talking about receiving it fit
it right into the actual lining your
teeth and put the whole thing in your
mouth and let it soak for a second
before you bust up with your tongue yeah
she's on that same cookie for 15 minutes
yeah because she actually picks it up at
points and goes nibble and puts it back
down that doesn't make any sense there's
nothing better than snapping a cookie in
half like bein over but I'll dunk it in
milk and opponents snap that
I couldn't even tell you the thickness
of one Pringle because I reach down and
then my two fingers snag whatever they
can snag and then that stack goes in my
face like an armadillo you get
your little fingers in there oh the boat
the least you're gonna get out of me is
two and that'll be if I flip one around
then I make the duckbill with it it as a
fun kissy face yeah go and then and then
that's it besides that they're going in
three four stack Pringles what's the
sense I'm walking through Tate's cookies
you line up for in front of me that's
nothing you open a rack you're eating
them it's why it's not a resealable
racks yeah dude I'll do a half a rack on
my head yeah finish a rat you know
what I'll be finishing it right art eats
nationwide are the only east coast I
don't know but they're very hot gotten
extremely popular now cuz man when I got
onto Tate's cookies dumping them in milk
that's the thing you would eat a whole
rat you need half a rack and you'd be
like do I just take down this whole back
I gained so much weight he's my
girlfriend moved to LA and I would just
eat a bag of cookies a night without
your love I was like have you ever had
that throttle Rio at the bones yeah yeah
of course
come on I haven't told you think I've
been to this many carnivals and I have I
had if I have it sort of recently my
life it sounded like a gross idea now
it's great it's do fried Snickers that
they have that they're - yeah it's
really good eleska tears and i'ma have
to go by this place buddy
fried or everyone here is that a fried
Oreo no we're gonna bring him I had to
throw Lynn's nodding yeah I mean it's
believed its funnel cake wrapped around
yeah and it's like that kind of crispy
and dumb
let me ask this and I know this is just
a stone and working off his brain are
there fried Reese's peanut butter cups
this place we didn't get them we thought
it would be overkill between our
milkshakes cookie a bucket of fried
Oreos yeah and three fried Twinkies
you're eating like a kid who got left
alone I'll tell you this fried Twinkie
not quite as impressed with really I
don't like what the cream does I love
the fried Twinkie I thought the cream
turns yellow house weird a house divided
yeah it looks like pus okay now it gets
gross I'm a jelly filled donut guy
though so this is race can't it's a New
York City institution look at that yeah
Ray's candy store I mean zeppeli now
seems oh by the way in the front Oreos
this place maybe they all do seem to
have a weird little tail on them that
you can hold it and button the tail made
of like fried and that falls off and
gets powdered sugar on and then you can
eat those and pretend like you're not
eating the bottom of the holes
everything fried you just grab a handful
of fried and sugar like coke that's my
coke
yo you want do a bump of some fried and
powdered sugar I got hey you know I'm
doing no matter what J these three fried
peanut butter cups I had are hurting me
I really though want that do you have to
you for the Super Bowl are you going to
a friend's house yeah yeah are you going
to the same friend yeah yes yes yeah
yeah I will
because I couldn't assume a large what
I'm gonna need a wagon to carry I think
we ordered when they were closing and
like a half-hour and I think they were
just dump this like that I think they
did the cool thing oh yeah our friend
work at a fast food place one of the
best you swing through the drive-thru by
Lance for its closing and they just give
you a felonious amount of food yeah I've
used to just tears I mean like I
said now I'd never even thought about
that just ripping through I would fry
wah wah saw the fritters yes ginger
ninja coming through Sanjay I mean that
my greatest idea
Yeah right but now you fry them with
funnel cake around get your head
out of your ass Jacob what if I told you
that fry was inverted inverted Oh Jacob
on your picnic that was a
fantastic idea I'll defend them to the
death my my freedom to fart you have a
freedom to fart no we're arguing two
different things here I'm blown away no
pun intended by your willingness to
again it's me if I ripped ass real big
right I think it'll arias here's the I
would do it in the right circumstance
with the grouping we have no no with no
lit and probably no Corey - is good I
feel like we've we've I would feel more
if I did it first or second episode of
them being in the room if I fart I feel
I feel like a crazy person I think
that's nuts but as I said it's a deal
it's it's a feeling that I feel
comfortable enough you ripped ask the
same way you just did with Becky
Rodriguez sitting right there because I
know there's a wall I got a I got a
how do you think gas works got a
backstop goes out up you think your fart
just falls to the ground I mean it's
like hot air
no no heat rises and then here's the
thing it Christine's heard me fart about
actually it has expressed a thing where
she's she's said something about me
farting before that is I've done it more
now in the last year than she said I had
we talked - yeah so I said to her the
new year I'm gonna try not to like fart
around her like that so much now that's
the thing but it was Christine and I was
with Christine I wouldn't have thought
much about farting in front of her that
she would have had a problem with it the
fact that you far in front of her is
mind-blowing every night I fart for my
girl I meet your chick iiiii there's no
she farts a phony
she's farted in front of me Oh freak out
you don't the freaked out
Christine's farted in front of me
several times I mean I'm not like
now I'm not like running her face in it
but if I'm just I'll just crack one
randomly I'm not doing it
all the time but a fart every month one
a fart a month pretty funny you fart you
fart on this show I probably didn't fart
for at least two months check the tapes
almost daily check the tapes I
do not I do not fart daily oh my we
pointed it out when you please practice
on that was December it was December
that's more technical months it's like
rollover minutes how long till you
farted in front of your girlfriend ah
three months we'd hung out a couple
times we don't move I just farted and
laughed down with it or not I've had
girls that are like that's us where
are we up or down what's going on I
explained this the last time this
happened I don't know if it's because I
grew up just my mom and I and she would
fart dude my mom farted in front of my
girlfriends in one of the funniest ways
it's one of the hardest I've ever
laughed in my life and my mom never
realized that she farted
she unintentionally farted to get up to
walk her dogs
she's like I'm I walk the dogs yeah and
ripped one in front of my ex-girlfriend
a night and we laughed about it hard
yeah hard for a good three months and
eventually like she was like a you know
a good looking girl and she would Jude
she occasionally tooted but I wouldn't I
had an ex-girlfriend if Arden friend
she's like that's disgusting like all
right then I'll go in the other room
when I fart I hole in the bathroom and
turn on the sink which feels odd yeah I
don't think it feels weird I think
that's I think that's silly
I think that's silly now keep it
sexy Dan can't be a chick sitting around
farting no but I'm not saying but if I
catch you fart and it's like such an old
ladies don't make noises so she makes
noise that's fine but as much as she
goes away to fart Christine that's so
obvious those farts were happening
though in front of me I'd rather her do
them somewhere else okay there you go
you are probably getting six seven a
night go shoot your gun in the dirt
we have member art I mean Christine you
know it is it Cisco fire
mommy Christina our schedules are kind
of like on tracks you have to understand
we when we watch TV together at night
yeah so if I only watch like you know -
three hours TV or something a night when
I get home at late night it just mean
her sitting there which is one time when
you do all your farting yeah so I don't
want Christine if she if it happened
once here and there whatever who cares
but nicely she's cracking for farts on
me there's no no I'd be over it there's
no way a sexual partner of mine would
ever see me fart the way I fart in a
hotel room on the road when I'm by
myself if I'm gassy cuz I'm just ripping
it it's just some stream line and a
spread of cheek and stuff yeah but I'm
cracking it waving it laughs and it's
gonna stop I think it would be in front
of Christine and if it was you Christine
and Lynne would be my issue and for me
it's it would be Lynne only well I feel
comfortable enough with Cory and Lynn
that I feel like I could fart and they
won't be upset at me well they're not
gonna tell you they're upset well they
make a weird working environment I
didn't mean to I'm sorry
did I just lose them with fart yeah you
might get me to you just assume
everybody loves farts I'm sorry if i
lured you guys you used your power you
know they know that you're a legend you
guys to me comedy you said to them and
you abuse your genius powers they work
on you up and they go we like working
with Nicki cuz she doesn't force us to
film her farts that's not true at all I
was during a commercial break and I
thought it'd be funny to me Jay laughs
during the commercial why are we doing
this Shane to you yeah you crack this
during the read you hellofresh
tell me what's wrong with that time oh
my god okay that's not incredible timing
and you're right because what most
people don't realize about working in
radio is that it's a hungry job I mean
it hello fresh they take the guesswork
out of cooking by offering a wide the
gas work in they do get it and they feel
the classics that we know and love like
Chipotle's buy steak or greens farro oh
that's coming out sideways
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
dan maybe you could do a commercial for
them like that with you and you after
you fart what you say good burn your
hellofresh hi I'm Dan Soder the billions
and when I'm on set pretending that I'm
at work in the stock market hello from
work in my intestines hello ash hello
fresh or they let me I get so I get so
sanctimonious a narcissistic I direct
the commercial I go panning on my bot
okay back up it's my butt goodbye fresh
I go in a simple dog fart I'm not upset
with you at all okay I just want to
apologize to Lin and Christine and Cory
I'm sorry if I made you feel
uncomfortable with my butt noise
black-lit was not aimed at you it was
not a mean of disrespect white Lou if
you smelled it I dealt it J also yeah
some people thought like I learn I'm not
smelling other dudes farts at all J I
hear you now
I understand how you feel I want to
apologize for forcing you to smell my
farts when you didn't want to say it
made me feel gay J you're making me
smell dude farts well no that makes me
feel gay man J hold on and I understand
where you're coming from
I'm just not a gay just know that J look
at me just know it I am sorry for
putting you in that situation I feel
like sometimes I need to express myself
through farting and I can see how that
would hurt other people including you
I'm sorry for smelling my farts and if
it makes you feel gay we can explore
then
shut up come here just shut up shut your
damn mouth come over here kid you had me
at hello fresh scenes come on Matt to
them Jacob I'll send that to them you're
welcome you're welcome you guys
send food in a box be appreciative of
pure art oh the one time I'm looking at
my phone and Jays not at least I have a
conversation when I look at my phone
unlike Jay who will just stop talking
the second he looks at his phone
Christine's nodding yes you can't see it
it's off-camera but she can't wait to
jump behind my friends and come at me
[Music]
the things I've done for this one my hot
tag she's always like a tag team like a
hot tag like Christine she's like okay
this is gonna build up not even
figured we're metaphorically she went
yeah Jay you do do that all the time you
did you gave him the Brit oh that's what
that's what brick doesn't anchor the
ultimate betrayal
oh no blood
I fired my managers and twice because
they were mean the Christine
some say it's very sexy quality I seal
in head to tell me right now
what goes to bat for you she owes a
stand-up guy
the man of honor she was you know you do
Ju look at your food you never come
finished over there going Friday she was
hype man to me she's going like this
okay well let's get out of here
don't you fresher on I didn't even put
it together hi bro I need to see a
little more emotion out of Jacob no J
when I dip down you want me to dip them
in front of the door I'd say just make
it look real passionate passionate now
too much Jacob now I remember walking
over here watching a guy filled a rap
video and I was like what kind of
asshole and I was like it looks like
we're filming a rap video alright so
anyway so get up there yeah J's up you
gotta be here and we're both throwing
hands
bounce it on my head that's your butt on
my hand
erotically top teeth
see that's a good video let's ask about
kiss let's go hard yeah
[Laughter]
we got it done guys room tone
you think your friends would dig this
video then share it with them and tell
them to rate and review and you know
make us feel good about ourselves you
tell a friend they tell two friends yeah
it's a pyramid scheme of a radio show
comes the whole thing I got some Cutco
knives also if you're interested
oh I got Spider Cove so come to me if
you want the real one